يواصل الاف الاسرائيليين احتجاجاتهم
وفعالياتهم المناهضه لحكومه رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو يرددون هذا
الخطاب بشكل متواصل هذا الذي يدعو الى
اقاله رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين
نتنياهو بشكل فوري من جهه وكذلك يدعو الى
انتخابات مبكره في اسرائيل بشكل فوري ايضا
لاعاده الرهائن نتيجه غياب الثقه بالحكومه
الاسرائيليه هذه الفعاليات التي تتواصل
هنا في تل ابيب وفي عدد من المدن
الاسرائيليه المختلفه بمشاركه عدد كبير من
المحتجين الذين يقومون بتنفيذ فعاليات
مختلفه في المدن الاسرائيليه وكذلك بالقرب
من مقر اقامه رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
للدعوه
لاستعاده المخطوفين من جهه
القاله بمتنه بشكل فور نظرا
لقيام نتنياهو بعدم تمكنه من استعاده
المختطفين بعد مرور 100 يوما كما نرى في
هذا العداد الذي قاموا بوضعه بالقرب من
مقر وزاره الدفاع الاسرائيليه وسط تلبيب
هذه الفعاليات المتواصله التيي
الاون هنا ايض تي في سياق استمرار
المطالبات
باعاده المختطفين باي ثمن كما باتوا
يرددون في فعالياتهم حسن مسعود
الجزيره تلبيب